lors de son discours devant le congrès
le 3 juillet dernier et conformément aux
engagements qu'il avait pris devant les
français pendant la campagne
présidentielle le président de la
république a réaffirmé sa détermination
à réformer nos institutions pour les
moderniser les rendre plus efficaces et
permettre une meilleure représentation
de nos concitoyens dès septembre dernier
les loi organique et ordinaire pour la
confiance dans la vie politique ont
permis de clarifier les conditions
d'exercice du mandat de parlementaire et
de prévenir les conflits d'intérêts nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui porter une
nouvelle ambition qui requiert pour
partie une révision de notre loi
fondamentale dont la philosophie
d'ensemble sera bien entendu préserver
car il ne s'agit ni de revenir à la
quatrième république ni de passer à la
6e il s'agit bien au contraire de
revenir aux sources de notre vème
république une république dans laquelle
le gouvernement gouverne et dans
laquelle le parlement légifère et
contrôle pour ce faire des travaux
approfondis ont été menées par madame la
garde des sceaux en liaison avec le
ministre d'état ministre de l'intérieur
sur la base de ces travaux et à la
demande du président de la république
j'ai consulté le président de
l'assemblée nationale le président du
sénat et le président du conseil
économique social et environnemental qui
ont formulé des propositions utiles
j'ai également consulter l'ensemble des
groupes parlementaires
au delà des divergences politiques tous
ont insisté sur le nécessaire respect de
l'équilibré de notre fonctionnement
républicain et de notre parlementarisme
rationnalisé en particulier dans la
répartition des pouvoirs entre le
gouvernement et le par le vendredi
dernier le président de la république a
reçu ma présence le président du sénat
et le président de l'assemblée nationale
nous avons pu ensemble construire les
bases d'un accord possible
dès demain nous déposerons donc au
conseil d'état un projet de loi
constitutionnelle et dès la semaine
prochaine un projet de loi organique et
un projet de loi ordinaire
ces trois textes seront présentés
ensemble en conseil des ministres le 9
mai